[Music]
hold on pal
kids they grow up so fast these days
that's why it's important to start
thinking about the future now when I had
questions about investing there was only
that was me six months ago living in
constant fear of birds snatching my to
pay each year birds get stronger and
more clever they still are too pays to
make nests for their babies but aware
themselves must stand up and show these
bird bastards whose box with the bird
away net to pay this stylish net offers
a clear view of your luxurious hair and
protects it from greedy eagles and hawks
no more buying dozens of toupees every
week the bird away net to pay is the
last to pay you'll ever need I thought
my daughter's outdoor wedding would be
the perfect place to show off my new
hair I guess that Falcon thought
otherwise but thanks to Berto a net
rebate my confidence is through the roof
and my daughter and I are closer than
ever so what are you waiting for
order bird away net to pay with optional
scarecrow and feel like a man and now
for moms protect your child
the bird no take baby
[Applause]
[Music]
our product is gonna help a lot of
people